c'est la rentrée parlementaire et le
premier ministre voulu marquer le coup
quatre priorités concrètes
il y dévoile une liste de revendications
à forte teneur nationaliste est en
pointe même à une célèbre déclaration de
robert bourassa le québec forme une
nation distingue les de ses choix
le gouvernement veut décider seuls du
nombre de personnes admises sur son
territoire et rendre conditionnelle à la
réussite de tests de français et de
connaissance des valeurs québécoises
l'obtention de la résidence permanente
un compte tenu de la situation
démographique du québec
c'est très important l'intégration des
immigrants la sélection des immigrants
on réclame aussi le sujet tissement des
entreprises fédérales comme les banques
ou les télédiffuseurs à la loi 101
un engagement à ne jamais contester la
loi 21 sur la laïcité une déclaration
fiscale unique et pour être bien certain
d'être entendu québec rouvrira le bureau
à ottawa que philippe couillard avait
fermé un vrai partenariat
ça commence par le respect mutuel les
partis d'opposition ne sont pas
impressionnés
le pq estime que françois legault ne va
pas assez loin que ce soit ça commence
quand la sonas manger une date sur vos
mains
c'est manifestement projet les libéraux
lui reproche le contraire et monsieur
legault visiblement aime la chicane et
lui croit sincèrement que pour faire
avancer des dossiers d'avoir un bon
bonne confrontation avec le gouvernement
fédéral
c'est absolument nécessaire je veux
assurer des chefs des partis fédéraux
qu'on est de bonne foi qu'on veut
participer pleinement à la fédération
canadien si bloc québécois appuient sans
surprise les demandes du québec sont
légitimes et elles sont raisonnables
l'accueil est plus froid de la part des
autres chefs fédéraux particulièrement
ce qui a trait à l'imposition d'un test
de valeur je ne veux pas donner au
gouvernement le pouvoir de décider les
croyances pour vous permettre d'être une
qualifiée mais valence et de mieux aider
les francisation je ne suis pas d'accord
avec le tester valeur françois legault
dit miser sur la forte volonté exprimée
par les québécois pour forcer les chefs
fédéraux à donner suite à ces demandes
et les revendications constitutionnelles
autrefois mises de l'avant par le
premier ministre ne figure pas sur sa
liste cette année une chose à la fois
justifie françois legault ici hugo
lavallée radio canada québec